foreign
your digital presence has never been
more critical with constantly emerging
threats and Technologies staying ahead
of potential risk and safeguarding
sensitive information is crucial cyber
security involves protecting digital
systems networks and devices from
unauthorized access theft damage or
disruptions at its core cyber security
aims to ensure the availability
integrity and confidentiality of digital
systems and data and the global cyber
security Market projected to reach
whooping USD
366.10 billion by 2028 its evidence at
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals is on the rights and is
expected to increase in the future with
this growing need numerous career
opportunities are available in cyber
security field for individuals with
diverse backgrounds and skill sets some
of the job roles in this will include
security analyst penetration testers
cryptographers security consultant and
many others according to Glassdoor a
cyber security average salary in the
United States is around 92 000 per year
however in India it is 6 lakhs per annum
hey guys welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel this video will discuss
the five reasons to learn cyber security
in 2023 well staying up to date with
cyber security advancements and updating
security measures regularly is crucial
for individuals and organizations to
ensure optimal protections against cyber
threats with that in mind if you also
want to advance your career in the field
of cyber security then take up this
cyber security postgraduate program that
aims to provide you with the necessary
skills to become a proficient expert in
the fast developing area of cyber
security by enrolling in this program
you will stay up to date with latest
cyber security Trends this course covers
skills like Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
network security software development
security mobile and many more so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box below for more details
our Learners have experienced new
success in their career listen to their
experience find the simply lens Course
Review Link in the description box let's
now explore why it is crucial to learn
about cyber security in 2023. in the
current digital era five compelling
reasons highlights the importance of
gaining knowledge in this field first
growing demand the widespread adaption
of Technologies in our daily lives has
significantly increased the demand for
cyber Security Experts as a result there
is a growing demand for more qualified
professionals to fulfill this demand
next cyber threats are increasing some
of the significant cyber attacks of 2023
are in Nepal bank accounts were hacked
via a fake app named Nepali Nepali Kitty
shared on WhatsApp resulting in stolen
money then PayPal customers were
attacked with 34 942 user personal data
accessed by hackers for two days using a
credential stuffing Cyber attack and
then they look better ransomware
attacked on ION groups clear derivatives
Branch disrupted derivatives trading in
Europe the U.S and the UK with a threat
of sensitive data Publications this
severe attacks are becoming more
frequent and sophisticated and can cause
significant damage to individual
business and even Nations learning cyber
security can help you protect yourself
and others from these threats next
product person and business data cyber
security is essential for protecting
sensitive personal and business data
such as financial information
intellectual properties and personal
identity information by learning cyber
security you can help to ensure this
Safety and Security of this valuable
information next we have career
opportunities the demand for cyber
Security Professionals is increasing
creating many career opportunities for
individuals with cyber security
Knowledge and Skills a wide range of job
opportunities is available in cyber
security from entry level to senior
level cyber security positions and
finally High salary due to the growing
demand for cyber Security Professionals
cyber security job typically offers High
salaries making it a lucrative career
path for those with the necessary skills
and knowledge so are you concerned about
the safety of your digital information
cyber threats are on the rights today
and protecting your digital asset is
more crucial than ever our Celtic cyber
security bootcamp offers the latest
industry knowledge and cutting-edge
techniques to help you stay ahead of the
curve caltex cyber security bootcamp
offers defensive and offensive cyber
security training digital forensics
penetration testing infrastructure
design and more our curriculum lab and
guided practice expose you to various
sort of cyber security tools whether
you're new to the field or looking to
upgrade your skills our course caters to
your needs if you are interested in
advancing your career in cyber security
you can also consider a professional
certificate program in cyber security
red team this program has been developed
in collaboration with IIT kanpur and is
designed to transform you into a cyber
security expert enhancing your career
perspective in this field now let's take
a minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced huge success in their
careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year iopskilled with simple
Learners postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed practical examples it was
led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course be a learner first with
this we have come to the end of this
five reasons to learn cyber security in
2023 I hope this video was informative
and interesting if you have any queries
or need any help opting for any of the
courses please let us know in the
comment section below our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here